well another year another Game of
Thrones season comes to a wrap but I'm
going to talk about season five of Game
of Thrones that's a spoiler alert you
have been warned and by season five of
Game of Thrones I mean some things in
season five a game of Thrones more or
less dealing with the end of season five
of Game of Thrones there's so much to
talk about a season of Game of Thrones
I'm not going to touch on it all if I'm
just not gonna start out negative I mean
it no negative way but as this season
was going on it was my least favorite
game of Thrones season that's not to say
it's a [ __ ] Game of Thrones season I'm
just saying it's my least favorite Game
of Thrones season it's like pick your
least favorite Ninja Turtles Leonardo of
course why would I pick anyone else it's
not to say Leonardo sucks I'm just
saying he's my least favorite Ninja
Turtle that and Venus de Milo she never
existed though so is Leonardo but Game
of Thrones has always been the long game
I was like I'll stick with it we'll see
where this is going
we got a sweet-ass siege in the third -
the last episode of Game of Thrones
Season 5 yeah north of the wall [ __ ] oh
my god that was intense
mostly Helms deep stuff man it was like
cinematic quality she the four horsemen
all up there it was really better like
these guys are the harbingers they're
the doom bringers and they're here
Arthas [ __ ] raises an undead zombie
ice army from World of Warcraft what
that was by the way but Jon Snow has
bigger problems suddenly things happen
with Daenerys Targaryen I was really
looking forward to tyrion going over and
counseling her and he does for a day and
she hops on the dragon and leaves which
led to one man in the show reaching the
most important conclusion of his life
every [ __ ] dude was like I am never
gonna hit that I will say season 5 was
the most polarizing for those of you who
were not on Twitter at all the week
after that episode aired on Sansa Starks
wedding night she was raped by [ __ ]
bolton same guy who cut Theon's dick off
so the guy's pretty much no prize I'm
not gonna lie that scene was super hard
to watch and you just want to turn away
people took to Twitter man they were
like I'm done with Game of Thrones no
one gave me [ __ ] that the women in
Craster's keep got rekt no one gave a
[ __ ] that Joffrey Baratheon made those
two hookers brutalize themselves
probably sexually they're hookers so no
one care says Ted Bundy Daenerys
Targaryen raped on her wedding night no
one gave a [ __ ] it was literally the
same scenario but no one cared yet yes
it's different when you're a little girl
sold to another guy by your own brother
I don't be hungry too I got his [ __ ]
dick cut up no one cared little girl
gets burned alive by her father's orders
we've established really bad things
happen to really good people in this
this season as always because that's
pretty much what happens in Westeros
Sansa Stark on her wedding night
horrible horrible thing yes I imagine
that scene was Fariq because he's gonna
save her ass later because he'll be like
I don't want to see her go through that
[ __ ] too much and he does that he throws
that [ __ ] [ __ ] over the thing she
was a [ __ ] to she deserved a dime
moving on to other [ __ ] Stannis
Baratheon things are looking bad at
first it's like yeah the snows melting
it's like yes sir half the people left
anyway and so the red woman leaves
Stannis Baratheon is like we're marching
on Winterfell and you just see the
formation of the horses come around
you're like I think you're gonna die did
I do sure enough it was pretty much a
slaughter although Brienne of Tarth
comes up and she's like I was protecting
your brother Renly and you had him
killed admit it he was like yeah dude
and she's like okay by order of you
being a dick you're dead why she kills
him but the rule is I'm not saying he's
alive I am saying there is a rule I kind
of live by in shows and movies and that
is if you don't see them die you don't
know that they're dead because he said
do your duty and I'm sure she's gonna be
like I am gonna do my duty I'm gonna
help Sansa Stark and you're going to
help me do that that's by helping me you
will find atonement and killing your
brother I can see that [ __ ] happening
dad or he's just dead I think the Lions
are going to war with the Vipers though
gonna be honest on that one that Jaime
Lannister's daughter was like I know
you're my dad and I'm glad and they
embrace and she dies cuz she was
poisoned there's just no coming back
from that [ __ ] but maybe they want maybe
it's like politically it's just they're
going to get away with it I could see
that happening in a world of [ __ ] heads
like Westeros oh my god that Cersei
Lannister walk of shame whoa
that [ __ ] was super uncovered that was
bad like people are throwing [ __ ] and
piss on her seriously Atlantis there's
no ray of sunshine it's not like you had
warm feelings for the woman she deserves
to have horrific things happen to her
but it was just so classless that you're
like yeah but not like that
Antoni back man I don't know execute her
make it quick I'm all about the quick
deaths in my kingdom that [ __ ] was just
hard to watch and then she gets back and
the one exiled Grandmaster dudes like oh
we're gonna clean you up by the way
here's Franken Robo Hitler or whatever
the hell they made the mountain into
speaking to people who aren't dead he
ain't dead guys it's like this this is
why I think Jon Snow is alive over the
first book and this theory is as plain
as day in the first book the thing is
who is Jon Snow's mother who is she I'm
gonna keep it super vague for people who
haven't read the books cuz this series
kind of like a cool thing to reach your
own conclusion when you're reading it
you're like oh my god I see so clearly
more or less it's who is Jon Snow's
mother and it matters it's like who his
parents are completely [ __ ] matters
so are we really to believe Jon Snow is
dead when that theory is so [ __ ]
important to people is a theory really
who's the dead guy's parents oh it might
be this dead chicken that dead dude the
whole thing ends because it's like dead
person and dead person made dead person
know if the theories still out there and
important and apparently important to
george RR martin and that means jon snow
is still alive because if he's dead the
theory just doesn't matter at all plus
the red woman's there she's going to do
that prayer over him and be like Oh Lord
Allah bring him back to life and then
he's going to come back to life or
someone will point we've seen that
happen that one dude who got cleaved and
he got brought back he's like oh I've
got him brought back at tilling time Jon
Snow's is gonna have a bunch of stab
wounds but he's gonna look pretty sweet
his chicks dig scars hey he ain't dead
that one pedophile piece of [ __ ] that
Arya sliced up bees dead Jon Snow not
dead alright guys so Game of Thrones
Season 5 have you seen it what did you
think about this season compared to the
other season whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you